The Hollywood Reporter looks at actor  Hank Azaria telling Stephen Colbert he'd  be willing to step aside from his role  as the voice of a poo on The Simpsons  app who is an immigrant Indian character  who runs a convenience store on the show  The Simpsons Azaria and the show had  been criticized for portraying him as a  stereotype  Azaria addressed the issue on last  night's The Late Show  I'm perfectly willing and happy to step  aside or help transition it into  something new I really hope that's what  the Simpsons does and it just it Azaria  has said the idea that anyone is being  bullied based on app who really makes  him sad a lot of people don't feel sad  about it they feel angry when they look  at it and something to think about